Andreea is with us in denver hey aundrea
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I did
thank you for taking my home sure what's
up
I have kind of a long question but I'll
try to keep it brief my husband and I
were just looking for some guidance on
how to have him sit down and talk with
his mom about two different single stock
accounts one was given to him by his
uncle when he was about five or six and
then the other one was given to him by
his grandpa and their managed at a two
different states so two different
companies and his mom is the trustee on
one and the other one is in Atma we're
getting ready to start our baby step
four in two weeks and we really would
like to have all of those a chance
together and then we're also afraid
about one of them the state because it's
managed so poorly the state took his
sisters that was also given to after her
because they were not receiving
statements on so they the state took it
liquidated it and now she's having to go
through lawyers because the company
doesn't manage it very well his mom will
not budge and I don't think she thinks
that we are confident to manage it
ourselves and so we were wanting some
guidance on how he can sit down and talk
with her about that okay what's his
mother's problem is she a control freak
that's part of it so my husband is baby
a four and they were all given stalks
and a couple of the older siblings
squandered bears on you know vehicles
and how much money is in this account so
one is about $50,000 and the other one
is about fifteen okay and which one is
the Atma is the fifty thousand and
that's the one that
is managed by confi share at a Utah and
nut smut no one has control of except
your husband it's a uniform transfer to
minors act and when he turned 21 it was
his money no one has any say over that
whatsoever does he have the account
number he does contact them and move
them contact them and move the money
okay and tell your mother that's what
you did cuz you're like a grown butt man
alright
how old is your husband he's 30 no it's
time he'd be a grown but man then right
so we try to have this conversation we
need to have a conversation whether I'm
just gonna move the money okay if I can
have a conversation whether I'll try but
she does not have control over a nut ma
that's the danger of a nut might say
uniform transfer to minors act when you
turn 21
it's your money the custodian has no
place in this anymore okay all he needs
to do is notify him them that he's above
21 years old and he is taking his money
out of his account and moving it to
another of his accounts that's how that
works now the trust is a different issue
it's got 15,000 in it and I don't know
what the terms of the trust are hey
what's the terms of the trust I have no
idea and that's another problem is that
we cannot seem to find anybody that has
any other paperwork yeah okay well the
$50,000 100 that's the 50 I thought you
said the utmost 50 the item is 15 oh I
misunderstood I apologize okay well I
probably would sit on the utmost the
trust are you is your husband willing to
sever the relationship with his mother
in order to get his money no I think she
means well I don't ask that
I asked if your husband is willing to
sever the relationship with his mother
in order to get his money she's an
incompetent control freak boob that's
who you've just outlined for me she's
not someone that's going to go down
without fighting and she's convinced of
her own superiority of everyone else am
I missing something
no you tell this is not gonna go well
right you're not gonna walk in there I
don't have a magic pill you can make
mamma swallow and make her sweet she is
not sweet she means well but it is she's
completely out of bounds she's psycho
and so you're gonna have to see sits
down with her and challenges her on
anything it's not going to go well is it
right
there's no sweet words there's no amount
of appreciation of gratitude or
assurance of your competency that you
can give this woman that she's gonna go
suddenly oh yeah you're right I'm just
gonna give you the money I should have
done that three years ago I'm sorry I
didn't even think about it that
conversation is not going to occur is it
how do I not know so then you've got to
decide what you're gonna do and it's
okay with me if you walk away with the
money in the name of the relationship
mm-hmm what do you guys make a year
what's your household income so in
overtime he makes eighty-three and I
stay home with our kids
are you willing to go forward and just
forget that this money exists we
considered that at this point I feel
like we're already on that boat because
the only thing that was really scaring
us was the fact that like I said so he
wanted his sister still has her shares
it's not it's not even oh this just
started his sister's not involved in
this conversation his sister got her own
problems right two of you decide are you
gonna look $50,000 in the face and be
willing to walk away from it in order to
keep this crazy woman happy me and
that's okay thing if you choose to do
that but you really have probably only
two options one is that or two is take
her down okay because I don't think
you're gonna talk her into it do you no
okay so I mean if he wants to he could
go over there one more time and say mom
here's a situation or working this
system or working a proven plan we're
almost out of debt we're going to use
this for debt and for investing we have
a process here we're competent and mom
I'm 30 years old it's time you turn
lucid
and mom if you don't then you need to
understand that I'm never going to bring
it up again and you're gonna lose it all
and that's going to be on you and then
walk away and take your 15 thousand out
of the at my next day okay and you know
forget the 50 because you're not gonna
get it or be ready to take her down I
hire an attorney and sue her butt and
take the money away from her because
it's not her money get the terms of the
trust get control of it you're 30 years
old I doubt very seriously there's any
trust put together there that it can
that gives her complete control until
your husband is 80
I just don't believe that most of them
almost all of these things are done by
the time you're 30 so if she wants to
show you the terms of the trust or show
your attorney the terms of the trust but
you're gonna you know you're gonna spend
10 or 15 thousand bucks getting this 50
and you're gonna lose mom in the process
and that's okay if you want to do that
she might not be worth keeping around I
don't know and I'm not being sarcastic
because this woman's nuts I'm not sure I
want her around but I do not like her
after talking to you so you guys got to
have a decision on this but I just
there's not every you want to be nice
you want to convince people with
rational thought that I do too but you
can't convince crazy people with
rational thought it doesn't work you
can't have a conversation with someone
like this so he can try and I would take
one last stab at it
with the idea that at the end of that
conversation I'm going to have already
made up my mind I'm either gonna say
hands off it's all on you I'm not gonna
talk about it again go the next morning
get your 15 thousand out let her be
pissed about that but she'll get over it
and never bring up the 50 or hire an
attorney and take it from her and decide
which one you want to do after the
conversation but take one last stab at
the conversation and pray about it maybe
God will send a a spirit of favor into
the conversation I sure hope so but the
person you're describing is not someone
who is reasonable and so I don't think
you're gonna get a reasonable reaction I
think she thinks she's the God of this
trust
and I don't think it's gonna work I'm
sorry I wish I could give you more
encouragement but there's not any